if a woman was hired by a woman or a man
their boss said look I would like my tea
at 10 am I would like you to make salmon
sandwich with extra cheese at 12 please
you've got some work to do here and
there Etc that woman would be embracing
that yes I'm Miss Independent and by the
way your employer can suck you and don't
give a damn about you but when your
husband and I'm talking about
traditional man he is literally paying
for everything and he comes home and
says I will just like breakfast I would
like some dinner and just a piece of
Mind ah misogynist your husband is
willing to die for you he's like your
personal bodyguard when the feet breaks
in the house he's gonna wake up well
done go and fight him off let's see what
you can do did you hear that did you
hear that of course I damn heard it yeah
let me get a baseball bat and let me see
what's going on we could die and not
come back I'm telling him slay the day
babe and look at Ukraine men are dying
what happened to all the feminism they
love the kitchen though
true Geordie podcast